we have an article by Ralph schoneman
called Iraq and Kuwait a history
suppressed it's put out by that HS press
and it has the most comprehensive
history of the relationship between
Kuwait and Iraq that I've ever seen
and Ralph Shulman says that little is
known of the that the fact that there
has been a popular struggle for decades
to return the area of Kuwait to Iraq
which was part of for for many many
years
now this ferment has been not only been
in Iraq but also in Kuwait itself which
almond goes back and gives the history
of the area talks about Mesopotamia
which was the general large area in the
Near East before it was broken up by the
imperial powers after World War one for
several centuries Kuwait had been the
southern part of the Basra province of
the Ottoman Empire under the Turks the
Ottoman Empire which ruled that entire
region relief on the imago to the ad
mark for central from from northwestern
North Africa across to the Gulf region
and even the areas that the coastal
areas of the Arabian Peninsula at one
time at one time but the whole history
of the area is one of intrigue murder
and meddling by the Western imperialist
powers British first tried to detach the
area now known as Kuwait from the
Ottoman rule and they did this by trying
to get the brothers two brothers of the
Sheikh who was appointed by the Ottomans
to agree to take over and let the
British then run the area well the two
brothers refused two brothers of the
Sheikh Mubarak they refused and so
the British had Mubarak murder his two
brothers and then they got Mubarak to
agree that the that Kuwait would be
detached from the Ottoman Empire and be
part of the British Empire
well the Ottoman leaned a little bit on
Sheikh Mubarak and Mubarak decided that
he would renounce that accord with a
British the Ottoman Empire met its met
its demise after World War one when a
lot of promises that Britain and the
other allied powers had made to the
Arabs in order to secure their
assistance during the war were not kept
and the Allied powers divided up the
Middle East among themselves and their
associates so that Lebanon what we now
know is Lebanon Syria and these two
countries went under French control Iraq
the entire Gulf area Jordan and Egypt
went under British control that was
after World War one oil had already been
discovered in Iran and Iraq so oil is
central to this thing all the way back
to the beginning the boundaries that are
today under dispute were actually first
drawn up by a British High Commissioner
of Iraq in 1922 Kuwait wasn't even
present but one of the things that he
did do that's important for us to know
today was he put that Kuwait in there to
make Iraq a landlocked nation Kuwait was
severed from Basra the Iraqis did not
accept him the British in 1922 drew the
first lines in the sand delineating
boundaries for the first time in history
between Jordan Iraq Kuwait and Saudi
Arabia these lines drawn by Sir Percy
Cox in 1922 he was the British High
Commissioner in Baghdad these lines were
drawn deliberately to deprive Iraq of a
viable seaport the British wanted no
competition from Baghdad which was at
that time the cultural and commercial
of the Gulf region to their dominance of
the Persian Gulf where they converted no
less than 10 shape terms into colonies
including Kuwait during this time there
was tremendous opposition to the British
taking Kuwait from the area of Iraq and
the there was great ferment not only in
Iraq but also in Kuwait to join the two
areas back again and the two areas
remained even up until the 1940s very
close
for instance the postal service was
still run by the Iraqis in Kuwait up
until the start of World War two and the
curricula in Kuwaiti schools was Iraqi
curricula up until just after World War
two
in Kuwait there developed a free Kuwaiti
movement and it was a mass movement
within that little country and they
submitted a mass petition to the Iraqi
government and two to have Kuwait go
back to Iraq well the British found out
about it and they meanwhile the free
Iraqi the free Kuwaiti movement had
pressured the Sheikh to establish a
Legislative Council to have some form of
democracy there and the first meeting of
this Legislative Council this was in
1938 it passed a unanimous resolution
demanding the Kuwait be reverted to Iraq
these are the Kuwaiti themselves well
the Brittain got alarmed at all this and
so they told the Sheikh to they forced
him to dissolve the Legislative Council
and hunt down detain and execute all the
members now in Iraq a king was set up
name the name of the Ghazi and the
British ambassador told him to quit
support
the free kuwaiti movement but gauzy
refused and april 1939 he was found dead
people think the British did it and in
his place the Linfen faisal ii took over
but there was really the power and
control was in the hands of a fellow
named Nuri s saeed who was really a
british agent he was a stooge at
whatever the british want him to do now
after world war ii the u.s. penetrated
the area a lot said of the Baghdad pact
Turkey Iraq Iran Pakistan Great Britain
participated along with the United
States and of course the Iraqi premier s
Maria Sayid what who by the way had been
a officer in the Ottoman army he did
pretty much whatever the British wanted
him to but with the invasion of Egypt by
Britain and France and Israel in 1956
revolutionary fervor hit the area and it
was very difficult for Maria Syed to
control Iraq even though he publicly
supported the British in the French he
also asked them that in order to placate
the Iraqi national sentiment they should
return Kuwait to Iraq yuria Syed said
that he should well he put it up to a
vote of Baghdad pact rather to return
Kuwait to Iraq and all the members of
the Baghdad pact except Great Britain
voted to return Kuwait to Iraq well now
Iraq informed Britain it was preparing a
formal memorandum well supported by
documents and copies of secret
undertakings and understandings which
would be published before the world in
July 12 1958 on the necessity of
Kuwait's immediate returning to the
Union of Iraq and Jordan instead of
being separated well guess what happened
there because of that there was a
revolution which occurred on July 14th
958 overthrew Nuri Assad on the British
were at it again and of a fellow who
took over was Karim Qasim and it was a
coup which initially didn't alarm the
CIA or Washington because they were
really actually behind it but it was
more radical than what the US and the
CIA wanted Qasim continued to alienate
both the United States and Britain by
demanding the return of Kuwait and he
was particularly incensed when Britain
gave Kuwait its independence and in 1961
rather than turning it back over to Iraq
when Kuwait was given its independence
by the British in 1961 the Iraqis massed
troops on the border and threatened to
take the territory back by force but
Britain rushed military forces to Kuwait
and the Iraqis back down the Iraqis
threatened to do the very same thing in
1972 and 1976 well it looked like kasym
had to go and he did in February 63
another coup shook a rock
killing Qasim and who was in it well the
CIA of course the CIA actually on had an
airlift of arms to Iraq to help the coup
plotters and they brought in a fellow
who was more pliant to the United States
as a replacement and at that time they
dropped the opposition of Iraq to the
independence of Kuwait and Kuwait's
entry into the United States
now who was a prominent member of this
coup was none other than Saddam Hussein
but Saddam Hussein was a member of the
right-wing faction not a kind of a
centrist faction if you want to use
those terms as actually that took power
with the
killing of kasym but eventually the
rightists did take power and what ensued
was a general slaughter of the left
radicals the Communist Party members
trade unionist radicals of every sort
were tortured and killed with the CIA
giving directions according to this
article by mr. Sherman well throughout
the 70s the regime of Saddam Hussein
attempted to compromise with the Kuwaiti
rulers on Iraq and that they would drop
the provision of the return perhaps if
the Kuwaiti s would let them have access
to the former islands in the Gulf so
that they would have a port there the
foreign minister of Iraq visited Kuwait
City in 1972 so that they could work out
another problem which was that Kuwait
decided it was getting bigger and bigger
and bigger and bigger
Kuwait wanted more of the oil fields up
there in Iraq and so it surreptitiously
will not - certainly they started
expanding their borders by creating
border guards and border crossings
further to the north into Iraqi
territory and so Iraq was concerned
about this and wanted was stopped Saddam
had a number of very specific complaints
against Kuwait that he began voicing
really late late last spring and very
publicly in the course of the summer one
was just just that that Kuwait for years
had been extracting Iraqi oil and
selling it to that Kuwait was refusing
to to sell its oil at a higher price in
order to assist the Iraqi economy in
1986 the OPEC countries had set $18 per
barrel as the bench price for for the
world petroleum market but the Kuwaiti s
and the United Arab Emirates for quite a
long time since then had been over
producing forcing the price down as low
as about 13 dollars last June
that price was the best price that
industrialized countries and importers
like the United States were paying for
petroleum at constant dollars for more
than 40 years it was hurting the Iraqi
economy because the Iraqis had something
like seventy to eighty billion dollars
in debt from their war their eight-year
war with Iran during the 1980s and they
were demanding that the Iraqis forgive
those loans which had helped finance
that war there is another claim which
Saddam Hussein made and that's the fact
that there is a very significant oil
field in Iraq but a little tip of it
goes into Kuwait and they hired a Saeta
FA that will they actually purchased
Santa Fe drilling Corporation of
California for the summer 2.3 billion
the Kuwait ease did and the specialty of
Santa Fe drilling was going at an angle
so you could be on your territory but
sucking the oil out of somebody else's
territory and this is what the Kuwait
ease did they were they drilled the oil
wells on their land and then they were
sucking the oil out of the Iraqi side of
this huge oil field Kuwait was not
making any was not granting any Iraq but
quite without granting Iraq any
concessions on the debt that it had
accrued in the course of the iraq-iran
war so ah Saddam Hussein really felt
that Kuwait was out to get him and to
get Iraq so said I was saying the brute
that he is he moved in some people are
saying that the u.s. pulled off one of
the most brilliant Machiavellian
maneuvers in US diplomatic history let's
take a look at what seems to be the best
evidence on what was going on behind the
scenes and try to see what really
happened a lot of the spotlights and
some history books have been some other
events have indicated that maybe the
United States really pulled a slick one
on this
it seems that there are a lot there's a
lot of evidence and the Arabs and the
Iranians believe that to start out with
the Iraqis were tricked into attacking
Iran the CIA fed information to the
Iraqis that hey you can go ahead and
attack Iran they're pushovers they're
weak they won't fight the whole edifice
will come down well you know what
happens it was a terrible terrible
bloody war and with millions of deaths
on both sides and left both really
reeling the CIA of course was a very
important tool in the Cold War and
certainly it was important in building
up Saddam Hussein in Iraq I suppose most
of you have read already that the United
States in its support for Iraq all
during that war with Iran was giving
Iraq the best intelligence possible on
Iranian troop movements it was what I've
read is that they were giving them
real-time satellite information so that
they could confront and defeat the
Iranian forces in that war
of course why the United States was
helping out Iraq militarily and urging
them on they were also giving
clandestine help to the Iranians but
they were trying to keep both sides bled
white a deal has been made of the fact
that the United States helped arm Iraq
and that the United States provided
high-tech technologies in fact during
the year prior to the Iraqi invasion
something like 400 or more licenses were
granted for high-tech exports to Iraq
much less attention has been paid to
what seems to have been a complicity
between the United States in Iraq to
increase oil prices generally the United
States according to the London observer
Bush sent an envoy who next ambassador
and it's not clear who it was to Hussein
in January of 1990 suggesting that he
push OPEC the cut back production enough
to raise oil prices to $25 a barrel
Hussein got the same advice apparently
from a US think tank who was hired
direct make recommendations about Iraqi
economic policy
suggesting that $25 a barrel would bring
in a lot more money would help it deal
with its debt problems would help a deal
with his reconstruction problems after
the iraq-iran war without provoking any
massive increase in conservation without
provoking any kind of shift to other
energy sources right in other words the
price would be higher but it wouldn't be
too high so apparently the united states
in iraq had agreed about that with this
and it there's also indications that
also iran agreed with this because they
also wanted to rebuild themselves after
the war and then even saudi arabia went
along with this and the two hold outs
were Kuwait in the United Arab Emirates
who are both pumping more oil in their
OPEC quota allowed and they're and
driving down the price of oil it seemed
to be happy with having a new policeman
in OPEC they had never been happy with
the way the Saudi the Saudis managed
OPEC because the Saudis had no military
punch they couldn't threaten anybody or
bully anybody all they could do is
threaten to produce more oil and the
last time they did this in a serious
fashion there was a kind of price war in
within OPEC was back in 1986 and they
drove oil prices so far down that George
Bush then vice president jumped on a
plane and went flying to the Middle East
to implore the Saudis to stop pumping
oil and to get the price back up because
his Texas oil friends were losing money
hand over fist well heads were being
closed and the financial sector of the
southwest was going under because this
oil price had fallen so low so already
in 1986 Bush was actively in personally
supporting a high oil price
the US has demonized Saddam Hussein as
being an absolute villain a monster a
torturer and killer of his people which
even which he is and during that time
the State Department put out a human
rights report that detailed some of the
atrocities that Saddam Hussein had
committed against his people James Baker
the head of the State Department a Texas
oil man Bush's bosom buddy said hey we
can't publish this report because Iraq
and Saddam Hussein are friends they're
getting well prices higher for us we're
working closely with them so we don't
want to annul II
that but they intervened with Congress
to prevent Congress from passing
sanctions against the Iraqis for these
same reasons and by that time it should
be noted Amnesty International and
Middle East Watch had accumulated so
much evidence of the horrors of the
Saddam Hussein regime that shortly after
the invasion they would have put a book
out a book a whole book detailing this
and this is what the Bush administration
was trying to suppress at that point in
time because the Bush and the Iraqis
were agreed on high oil prices no that
is not what the war is about they went
to war when Hussein went beyond the
least that he had been given when he
sees when he sees to be merely the cop
of OPEC right and he tried to become
OPEC by taking over the Kuwaiti oil
fields you would have had our oil
reserves as big as Saudi Arabia and he
obviously was on his way to establishing
his own personal control over the whole
area that's a something kind of thing
with the United States clearly is not
about to accept not from Iraq not from
Iran not from Assad in Syria or anybody
else so they saw him as a hegemonic
threat in the region who is trying to
control more resource usurp American
influence and they wanted him to it's
one thing to bully Kuwait into cutting
back its oil production so oil prices
can be high it's another thing to be
throwing around this gigantic army that
he's got right and doing what he wants
to do independently of Washington this
discussion that we're now having is put
in an interesting context in an article
by Craig Hulett called the secret US
agenda of the Gulf War that indicates
that in April of 1990 there was a White
House conference a meeting of members of
the ruling classes of all the European
countries and they put out a taskforce
report on this conference and it was
published by Derek Fitzgerald the former
prime minister of Ireland who wanted
people to know what was discussed at
this conference and according to this
article this analysis by Craig Hulett
who's a former military defense analyst
who is now an independent researcher
working in Seattle Washington with a
group KC & Associates that's a group of
retired intelligence officers military
people generals and some former National
Security Administration people are now
criticizing as john stockwell did their
former employees and they have published
an analysis of the Gulf War from the
context of this report that was
published in April of 1990 that said
that the Middle East needs to be
completely disarmed that the ballistic
missiles the conventional weapons the
nuclear the chemical everything has to
be taken out and the main threat to
stability of the region is Saddam
Hussein and his military machine and it
needs to be destroyed completely in
order to guarantee the stability of the
region they talked about how this could
be done through the UN and through
utilizing some sort of UN resolutions to
try to demilitarize the Middle East and
they came to the conclusion this isn't
practical only through a war could the
military machine of saddam hussein be
destroyed and according to Hulett this
consensus that was built up among the
power elites of these European countries
would explain why in the United Nations
Bush was able to get all of these
countries that are usually squabbling
right behind him to pass all of these
resolutions that they'd already agreed
that Saddam Hussein's military was a
menace to the peace this ability which
means the flow of oil and controlled by
US and European interests of that region
for their own ends and that therefore he
needed to be taken out
now what's chilling about this when you
think of it in the context of the future
is that they concluded that all of these
military machines Syria Qaddafi Saddam
Hussein that all of these military
regimes were a threat and that the
military had to be completely eliminated
in every one of these
good James what about Israel they they
don't mention Israel which is of course
the biggest military machine in the
region with the most nuclear weapons
chemical biological in fact when they
kept saying that Iraq during the Persian
Gulf War had the fourth largest military
machine in the world they conveniently
left Israel out of this that has a much
larger military machine than Iraq was an
authoritative article published by a man
called Benjamin in Haaretz who's a
senior political commentator in Israel
it was published around the middle of
August of 1990 two weeks after the
crisis began in which he put forward the
views of the Israeli government and
essentially they are the regime of
Saddam Hussein has to be destroyed its
military capacity has to be destroyed
it's it's its industrial capacity has to
be destroyed and in fact the kind of
bombing that that only a massive
airstrike could accomplish would have
the effect of setting back Iraq for
roughly two generations and this was
exactly echoed a few days ago in the
Washington Post by General Duggan the
army the Air Force chief of staff you
recall who was fired by Cheney a couple
of days later but the Israeli view has
because I think had a kind of hegemony
has prevailed in planning in Washington
I believe to a fantastic degree that the
only way to deal with this particular
crisis which is a real crisis is
essentially military and I have a very
great fear that the military solution is
in fact the only solution acceptable
both to the Israelis and to the United
States at this point unless some air is
cause some some Sun is let in me and it
opens up and the Israeli position is
very simply that any sign of Arab of
Arab strength
any sign of Arab
of capacity for mobilizing for in fact
providing a real deterrence to Israeli
superiority which is assured principally
by the United States has to be hit now
this group you're talking about you was
a secret things I don't remember seeing
about it reading about they've been
trying to publicize this they've been
meeting with I mean the group Leo K this
task force this is the first I've read
of this and it was at the private
conference of the White House in the
April of 1990 and with 0s
European and major players in the
geopolitical power game and they put out
a report afterwards that was actually
published and they got hold of the
Derrick Fitzgerald who was a former
prime minister of Ireland decided that
this should be released but it indicates
one why the UN coalition operated as
smoothly and quickly as it did why Bush
was able to get all these European
countries on board and that is because
there was a consensus that you had to
take out these military machines in the
Mideast well this was the sink was the
point of providing so much help to Iran
in its war against Iraq they were trying
to bleed both countries all right they
just totaled who they would wipe each
other out but it didn't work out that
well it didn't work out that way because
the military machine of Saddam Hussein
became more and more vast because the US
and the European countries sold him such
a fantastic amount of military equipment
that he was able to build up his machine
during the iran-iraq war rather than
having his military wiped out so mr.
Bush who supported Iraq every year with
4.5 billion dollars worth the five
credits used to buy arms it was you who
were warned On February 24th by King
Hussein
and by president hosni more about Egypt
that Saddam was threatening reprisals on
Kuwait your answer was to send your
friend Robert Dahl on April 12th to
assure Saddam of your support and your
friendship
according to transcripts of that meeting
you knew 214 Bell helicopter's we sold
to Iraq and use for their military you
know that the 1985 shipment of the rare
West Nile fever virus from the US Center
for Disease Control ended up in Iraq as
part of its biological warfare program
you knew of the gassing of Kurds and yet
you still tried to defeat the sanctions
against Iraq passed by Congress on July
27 in the meantime on the political
front when Reagan came to power Oh bill
Casey saw that he had a rather
significant adversary or at least a very
experienced person in the form of
ambassador to the United States from
Saudi Arabia a very capable experienced
man so William Casey managed to maneuver
and get rid of this person and get got
prints bombed our appointed as
ambassador to the United States Bridge
Banda is very inexperienced but he was a
member of the ruling family so he had
direct links to the power structure and
Casey found that he could manipulate
this Prince and feed him bad information
so this turned out to be part of the
equation
National Security Adviser Scout Croft
Scowcroft showed some top-secret
documents quote-unquote to prince bond
are showing that Saddam Hussein was
going to invade Saudi Arabia but the
documents were actually bogus a little
later we'll Bondar ask his government
in a great panic for US troops to be
sent in and of course that's the way the
Saudis were brought into it
Treecko Treecko right well on the
Kuwaiti front it seems that CA da CIA
documents have emerged as a result of
the Iraqi invasion indicating that the
Americans were playing a game
tricking Kuwait they were telling Kuwait
hey go ahead and stand firm on the
problems you're having with Iraq the
Iraq has these certain demands they're
making of you and they want to negotiate
with you but stand firm don't give in to
them because Iraq is in a weakened
position and we're going to back you all
the way June and July there is some
circumstantial evidence to indicate that
there may very well have been a major
Central Intelligence Agency and in
intelligence Support Activity undergone
by the Pentagon of covert action to
remove Saddam Hussein from his position
of leadership the August 19th Washington
Post says on August 10th at the Arab
summit conference in Cairo
Kuwait's foreign minister Sabah Ahmed
Sabah confronted Iraq's foreign minister
Tariq Aziz publicly accusing Iraq of an
unprovoked aggression in violation of
international law in Tariq Aziz the
foreign minister from Iraq pointed to
the Kuwaiti foreign minister and said
you beware we possess and will reveal to
the world the contents of your
conversations and documents in
communications between the Kuwaiti
foreign ministry and the United States
Central Intelligence Agency and if your
plans to take steps to deal with Saddam
Hussein and the foreign minister of
Kuwait fainted dead away in April the
Assistant Secretary of State for Middle
Eastern affairs
a man whose name is John Kelly testified
before the US Congress that the United
States had no commitment to defend
Kuwait in July the OPEC oil ministers
met in Geneva
that's mid-july and Iraq was demanding a
raise in the oil price and also the
elimination of overproduction on the
part of Kuwait and the Emirates Iraq at
that time asked 30,000 troops on the
Kuwaiti border Hussein got part of what
he wanted the the Emirates and Kuwait
agreed to start over producing new
quotas were said in order to maintain a
new price of $21 per barrel
even though Iraq had asked for 25 in any
case things were not settled even with
that because Iraq was continuing to
demand that Kuwait leased to Iraq two
small islands booby under guava in the
at the head of the Persian Gulf which
would have provided Iraq with a viable
seaport Kuwait refused who eight also
refused to forgive the loans that had
been made to finance Iraq's war with
Iran negotiators met in Saudi Arabia
between the two countries on the 1st of
August Kuwait did not compromise and the
next day Saddam Hussein invaded well the
United States was not unaware that this
was coming by any means on April 25th
some of you have read this I'm sure
honey I mean on July 25th April blessed
be the US ambassador to Iraq had a
meeting a face-to-face meeting with
Saddam Hussein at that meeting she said
according to a transcript
apparently the Iraqis recorded the
conversation secretly and later made
available the transcript a transcript
which by the way has not been disputed
by the Department of State at this
meeting the US ambassador said to Saddam
Hussein I have a direct instruction from
the Secretary of State to emphasize to
you that the United States has
quote/unquote no opinion on your border
disputes with Kuwait she also said I
have an instruction from the President
to seek better
relations with Iraq at this time there
were 100,000 Iraqi troops poised on the
border because after the OPEC conference
in Geneva in Geneva in mid-july
the Iraqis did not withdraw those 30,000
troops they more than tripled them to
something like 100 thousand during this
time also in the days following or the
week following the ambassador's meeting
with the Seine up to the invasion the
CIA according to press reports and
according to senator Boren who is the
chairman of the Senate Intelligence
Committee the CIA was predicting that
Iraq would invade Kuwait and in fact in
the meeting between the u.s. Ambassador
and Hussein Hussein himself responded to
her saying in effect that he was going
to take drastic action against Kuwait if
they did not agree to his demands so it
was as clear as crystal
I believe that Hussein was going to
invade Kuwait but during the that week
that crucial week between the
ambassador's meeting with the sane and
the invasion with those 100,000 Iraqi
troops on the border the Bush
administration did absolutely nothing
and there were things they could have
done they could have called for example
aid an emergency meeting of the United
Nations Security Council they could have
sent a multinational military force to
Kuwait to defend that country just as
the British had done earlier they could
have issued public warnings but they did
something to the contrary they
prohibited the United States Information
Agency from making a warning to Hussein
on a program that had been scheduled the
Assistant Secretary of State John Kelly
himself killed that program and forbid
any US government warnings to Hussein or
to the thousands of people who might
become hostages in the event of an
invasion of Kuwait then two days before
the invasion the same Assistant
Secretary of State John Kelly goes
before the Congress one more time and
again he says the United States has no
commitment to defend Kuwait well put all
those things together and it certainly
seems to add up to a situation in which
the United State
was enticing or encouraging Hussein to
take over Kuwait